[Music]
so we just saw a new presentation of the
division uh and though we didn't get to
play it we did get a bit more
information about how this game actually
plays that's kind of one of the things
Ubisoft has been a bit Cy about is what
is actually happening you know across
larger sections of the game what kind of
things you actually doing and one of the
things that they were talking about is
wanting to let you play endlessly sort
of in the same way that Activision was
saying about Des
uh and a lot of that has to do with
acquiring better items and and there's
you know very RPG like uh tear of I
wouldn't say loot but you know weapons
and uh equipment and that kind of thing
well yeah I mean the game director that
we spoke to he said while the items
didn't have tears per se you know that
there were definitely progressions that
would affect the statistics of your
characters so you know like he he did
use the terms legendary and epic uh
specifically if you will but I don't
know like I don't think he meant that
the game itself would have epic they're
not going to be you know yeah blue and
purple items NE they could I mean the
game's not finalized yet we do want uh
an item progression and we want to
reward players for spending more time in
the game for going further in the game
uh you obviously endgame is a big part
of what we want for the division we want
to have content for players to play for
endlessly uh would be the ideal um goal
for that for the game so you need to
supply that with new items and new
weapons that constantly get more
powerful um but as to the specifics of
tearing we don't actually do that in the
game but they do get better kind of
sounds like almost like an MMO to me you
know like I feel like that's almost the
direction that they're kind of heading
in with the division well it's not
necessarily an MMO but it is still one
of those you know shared World
experiences where it's like sort of
Co-op sort of PVP but they're trying to
do it in a in a seamless manner that
makes you not have to think about
grouping up and and joining a party and
and all that rigar roll but they are
maintaining what they call the Holy
Trinity from MMOs you've got you know
your tank your support character which
could be a Healer and you've got your
damage character as well yep and that
being said though he um the characters
aren't really limited to these like you
can still have three damag characters go
take on a mission or like even four
tanky characters you're not penalized
heavily for just having all everyone
like take on that one role but at the
same time he said you know the developer
the game director sorry said that they
were aiming for a way to to encourage
players to to go with a varied party to
maximize the most that they can get out
of the division yeah I've always found
it a bit strange when people try and
bring those roles over to a modern
shooter because you know bullets don't
really discriminate but you know there's
still I guess you can have heavily
armored characters you can have
characters with flamethrowers or or
whatever have you um one of the things I
thought was interesting uh when you
asked him can the Drone pH get shot down
uh yeah it actually can so the idea that
you have this support character playing
as a tablet they aren't completely
Invincible they are still vulnerable and
they still provide pretty significant
abilities to the other four players on
the ground that's right and all those
players also um form like they they
generate or threat or aggro you know he
did say that there was an aggro system
present in this game as well which you
know struck me as very familiar because
I'm a big MMO person and you know that
the fact that there's an aggro system to
manage or to look out for as well in the
division I thought was quite a surprise
yeah one of the things that I've always
tried to figure out with this game is
what is the broad goal what are you
actually trying to work towards and when
he brought up the they call it the mega
map in the D it just looks like a map to
me I don't know what's Omega about it
but he brings that up and there are
these different areas that are marked
off that are called events and I asked
him like well what's the difference
between that and one of the named
buildings and you know he was talking
about maybe one of those will have more
significant story events as in like a
main mission or that kind of thing there
is stuff that is uh uh potentially more
important that will be tied to the
narrative that will be apparent on your
map uh uh that when we open the map in
that demo that we have that we just went
through it's a more progressed map
there's a lot of information that would
be much further on in your progression
in a district uh than when you're in the
game and first coming in um we don't use
fog of War cuz it's New York everyone
knows the streets of New York we're a
Clancy agency we have a high-tech gear
so you know the streets but you don't
necessarily know the status of a street
what's happening there um you know those
kind of things so as you upgrade your
base the modules in your base you can
get more information about what's
happening in the surrounding District as
you're going through the different
districts you can see on the mega map
what the security level is uh what the
infection level is and you're sort of
trying to affect those values to not so
much rebuild a district but just bring a
little bit more order and security to it
in the mega map actually uh there's also
dark zones that are available which you
know leads us to the whole other world
of PVP available in the game and he did
touch upon that as well so you know
players who are sort of wandering in the
dark zone are susceptible to being
attacked by other players alone but at
the same time if you don't want to
participate in that sort of combat then
you can just stay away from the dark
zones and just have a game with you and
your friend yeah I'm seeing a lot of
similari to Destiny and sort of just the
high level structure so you've got uh
The Hub World which is where players
from any division will run into each
other as they go and I guess visit
vendors or you know party up and check
their inventories and that sort of thing
uh you've got the dark zones which are
essentially what sounds like The
Crucible PVP section uh and then you
just have the actual uh districts of New
York themselves which equate to areas
where story missions and side missions
take place and when you're in those
districts you're never going to
encounter an player or someone who's not
from your division that area is entirely
self-contained and for you to
explore